jamais ces trois mots prononcés il ya 25
ans seront à jamais gravé dans
l'histoire des franco ontariens un cri
du coeur lancé lors d'un grand
rassemblement en mars 1997 qui a eu
l'effet d'un électrochoc
n'oublierai jamais fermé montfort jamais
ciel
ce jour-là gisèle lalonde est devenu le
fer de lance de la bataille contre le
gouvernement conservateur de mike harris
qui menaçait de fermer l'hôpital
montfort le seul hôpital de langue
française de l'ontario une bataille qui
prendra fin par une victoire historique
en cour d'appel la francophonie
ontarienne aujourd'hui jouit d'une
protection fonctionnelle on a droit tout
les avons non seulement pour survivre
pour s'épanouir le dossier monfort qui
les fameux principe m'ont forcée des
plus beaux sinon
dans l'histoire du canada c'est gisèle
lalonde en héritage qu'elle menait c'est
vraiment de nous de nous dire ça vaut la
peine de se bat
gisela lalonde a d'abord fait carrière
dans l'enseignement avant s'impliquer au
sein de nombreux organismes
franco-ontariens
après avoir tenté sa chance en politique
provinciale
elle devient mère s de vanier en
1985 et là aussi elle a livré bataille
notamment contre les fusions municipales
gisèle lalonde était avant tout une mère
de famille celle de trois enfants qui
ont dû partager leur mère avec toute une
communauté
très fier on réalisait l'absence de mama
peut sans trop connaître leur plein de
sang réplication alors quand on raconte
déjà comme ça qui nous reconnaissent ou
qui ou qui nous rappelle ou encore le
téléphone c'est toujours prêtes shop
savoir quelle qu'elle a eu un
incident gisèle lalonde s'est éteinte à
l'âge de 89 ans à l'hôpital qu'elle a
tant aimé et défendu et beaucoup
d'émotion présentement ces gens étaient
très attachés injuste elle donc pour
l'instant c'est vraiment un deuil
collectif qu'on ressent après l annonce
de son décès plusieurs citoyens se sont
rendus tout naturellement devant
l'hôpital réplication le mouvement sos
montfort a fait en sorte que partout
canada l'on parle des franco-ontariens
et puis vous savez qu'on existe elle est
vraiment eu un très bon impact sur
plusieurs francophones à la montre et la
langue ils se sont battus on s'est
battus puis ça donnait quelque chose il
faut continuer pour la famille de gisèle
lalonde c'est un moment de tristesse
mais aussi de solidarité peut-être
qu'aujourd'hui avec son dessin pour 16
pb que c'est peut-être encore
aujourd'hui un moment
ici nathalie tremblay radio canada
ottawa